as women won't go down in lifestyle in  order to have a family so like if  something something they normally with  self because men are gonna more selfish  so no I I think women are more I'll give  you an example okay and I don't I don't  mean to pick on you but like you your  nails done right yeah and I noticed most  girls that come on my show have their  nails done and they they usually have  very nice clothes and it's like it's  like lifestyle  but and and so like I've asked this  question where I say would you go down  in lifestyle like you make this much  money would you go down to this  lifestyle at forty thousand thirty  thousand dollars for a year for a family  and they say no